Now,
what makes good design is one of the
biggest questions and one of the hardest
questions to answer sometimes people ask
us,
how do you decide to put an object in
the collection of Moma?
Because,
you know,
it's a small collection.
It's not huge.
It's about 4,000 objects.
Um,
you can talk about anything you want
form function,
all of these different equations that
have been,
um,
usually,
you know,
they have been given the world as
possible definitions.
But the truth is this,
um,
it's a very complex recipe.
The world has become more complex and
you can't any more have an equation with
just two variables.
There's like,
you know,
it's a differential equation with many
variables.
What I can tell you is one of the litmus
tests is think if this object would not
on earth,
would it be a pet?
Would you miss it?
I tell you,
that's really interesting because it
really helps sometimes objects are not
immediately functional.
They're not to be set upon to be used to
eat or to be used to turn on the volume.
Sometimes objects just delivery emotions
or are just part of your life.
That's also enough,
you know,
the moment an object seems necessary,
then you can move on to judge if it's
beautiful,
if it works well,
if it's a fit,
wastes energy.
Those are all considerations,
but the idea of necessity or good
addition to the world really usually
works.